REPUBLICANS TAKE THE HOUSE, WE
WILL BAKE BACK IN THE MEANTIME
NEARLY ONE WEEK SINCE THE
MIDTERM IS STILL A LOT UNDECIDE
LET'S SPRING OUTBREAK AND SHIP
ROY HE'S A MEMBER OF THE HORSE
HOUSE.
THE WHOLE THING AS CONGRESSMAN
THANK YOU FOR COMING WE
APPRECIATE IT WENT TO GET YOUR
CHECK BECAUSE IT WENT SEAT AWAY
FROM CONTROLLING THE HOUSE.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN AND I THINK WE'LL HAVE
THE MAJORITY AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING.
IF YOU GOT THE GAVEL, YOU CAN D
WHAT YOU NEED TO DO TO MAKE SUR
WE HOLD AS ADMINISTRATION
ACCOUNTABLE.
REPUBLICANS IN THE CONFERENCE
WERE UNITED WANTING TO HOLD
DEMOCRATS ACCOUNTABLE.
THE QUESTION IS HOW TO DO IT.
IF YOU KEEP DOING THE SAME OUT
THAT YOUR KENAH GET WHAT YOU
ALWAYS GOT.
THERE'S IS A RECENT
CONGRESSIONAL APPROVAL IS ALWAY
BELOW 20 PERCENT THE MATTER WHO
IS IN THE MAJORITY.
THERE'S IS REASON WERE IN DEBT.
THERE'S A REASON WHY THE DIVORC
ARE STILL WIDE OPEN.
IT'S TIME FOR SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
TO COME IN HERE AND CONTINUE TH
STATUS QUO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR, WHEN YOU
DON'T PERFORM THE WAY YOU SHED,
USUALLY THERE'S SOME SORT OF
CHANGE.
REPUBLICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DID PRETTY WELL.
GOVERNOR DESANTIS SWEPT IN
FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT WELL IN TEXAS.
LEE'S ELDON HAD A SPIRITED
CAMPAIGN IN NEW YORK.
THE LETTER AND IN TENNESSEE DID
EXCEPTIONALLY WELL.
WE DID ACTUALLY VERY WELL IN
SOUTH TEXAS WE DID NOT GET ALL
THE SEATS WE WANTED TO GET BUT
WHEN SOME LOCAL ELECTIONS.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
'S BECAUSE RENT-A-CENTER IS A
GOVERNOR LEAD.
THEY SENT MIGRANTS TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD THEY STARTED TO HELP
TURN ELECTION AROUND OUR
REPUBLICANS WERE FIDDLING.
WE NEED TO CHANGE AND EARN
PEOPLE'S RESPECT AND THAT START
TOMORROW WITH HAVING A
FULL-FLEDGED DEBATE ABOUT THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS PARTY AND TH
LEADERSHIP OF THIS COUNTRY.
WE NEED TO ACTUALLY MAKE SURE
WILL REPRESENT THE PEOPLE.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE]
>> IT BRINGS UP OUR NEXT PLATE
YOU TALK ABOUT LEADERSHIP LISA
BILL BELLUCCI REPORTED ANDY
BIGGS FROM ARIZONA SAID HE WILL
CHALLENGE TREVOR MCCARTHY.
YOU SEE A BIGGER BATTLE LOOMING?
IS.
>> I THINK WHAT YOU'LL FIND OUT
TOMORROW IS THAT THERE IS NO ON
IN WASHINGTON THAT CURRENTLY HA
218 VOTES FOR THE SPEAKERSHIP.
KEVIN IS A FRIEND ANDY BIGGS IS
A FRIEND.
TOMORROW WE WILL HAVE A ROBUST
DEBATE AND I THINK PROBABLY
SPEAK UP LATER MCCARTHY WILL GE
THE NOMINATION AND A MAJORITY
VOTE AMONG REPUBLICANS.
HERE'S WHAT WILL BE CLEAR IS
THAT HE NOR NO ONE HAS 218 VOTES
.
WE NEED TO GET BUSY AS A
REPUBLICAN CONFERENCE IS SITTIN
DOWN AND FIGURING OUT HOW WE
WILL CHANGE THE RULES AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY PUT OUT AN AGENDA
THAT WILL INSPIRE AMERICANS
INSPIRE A GENERATION C INSPIRE
YOUNG WOMEN AND EVERYONE ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T BLAME IT ON
REDISTRICTING YOU CAN'T GO
AROUND AND SAY WELL WE RAISED
$500 MILLION WITH IT ALL THE
STUFF IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT POWER.
HERE'S WHAT WILL HAPPEN YOU HAV
REPUBLICANS SAYING WE DON'T HAV
60 IN THE SENATE.
WE NEED TO HOLD ONTO POWER IN
THE HOUSE.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO DO THE HAR
WORK AND MAKE SURE WE FIGHT FOR
REPUBLICANS WHO NEED IT?
TOMORROW IS ABOUT CHANGE WE NEE
TO CHANGE THE WAY WE DO THINGS
IN WASHINGTON.
I'M GLAD ANDY BIGGS IS RUNNING.
>> TOMORROW IS ABOUT FORMER
TRUMPET SOME TYPE OF
ANNOUNCEMENT.
IS HE GOING TO RUN IN YOUR
ESTIMATION, AND IF HE DOES,
SHETTY?
>> WE WILL FIND OUT TOMORROW OR
FIND OUT AT SOME POINT.
IT IS BEEN A LOT OF SPECULATION
COMING UP FOR A LONG TIME.
THAT'S UP TO HIM.
RIGHT NOW FOCUSED ON DOING MY
JOB IN THE HOUSE.
I THINK WE NEED TO BE MARCHING
FORWARD TO REPRESENT THE PEOPLE
IT'S THE PEOPLE'S HOUSE WERE
SUPPOSED TO ACTUALLY DO OUR PAR
IN MAKING SURE WE UPHOLD ARTICL
ONE YOU THE POWER OF THE PURSE
CHECK THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
LOOK, RENT DESANTIS WILL MAKE A
EXTRAORDINARY EXTRAORDINARY
CANDIDATE AS WELL IF SPEAKER
MCCARTHY OR LATER MCCARTHY
BECOME SPEAKER MCCARTHY, HE SAY
HIS PRIORITIES WOULD BE QUOTING
PROXY VOTING GOES AWAY,
MAGNETOMETERS GO AWAY.
BILL'S WORK TO COMMITTEES.
WHAT IS YOUR TYPE PRIORITY FOR
HIM?
>> THOSE THINGS ARE ALL GREAT
BUT THEY'RE KIND OF LIKE
BREATHING WAS IT THE THINGS WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
GET THE HOUSE BACK THE PROXY
VOTING IS ABSURD.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE SURE
WE WILL USE THE POWER OF THE
PURSE TO MANDATE THIS PRESIDENT
SECURE THE BORDER.
GOD BLESS A BILL TO CONTINUE TO
REPORT ABOUT THE TRAVESTY GOING
ON THAT AND PULLING INTO OUR
SCHOOLS KILLING AMERICANS 72,00
DEAD AMERICANS PULL WE
REPUBLICANS NEED TO USE THE
POWER OF THE PURSE TO CHECK IT
OUT OF CONTROL EXECUTIVE BRANCH
PRESIDENT BIDEN TOO STOP
SPENDING MONEY WE DON'T HAVE AN
WOULD BE TO MAKE SURE WE DO OUR
PART TO OPEN UP AMERICAN ENERGY
SO WE CAN HAVE THE GAS AND
ELECTRICITY THAT DESERVING CAN
AFFORD WE CANNOT JUST THEY WERE
GONNA PASS BILLS AND HAVE THEM
DIE IN THE SENATE IS THE POWER
OF THE PURSE TO FIGHT FOR THE
PEOPLE OPEN UP THE PROCESS IS S
ALL REPUBLICANS CAN USE THE
POWER OF THEIR ELECTION
CERTIFICATES TO GO IN AND
REPRESENT THEM.
NOT JUST A SPECIAL INTEREST OR
THE POWERBROKERS SITTING IN THE
COMMITTEE CARDINALS ALL MEMBERS
OF THE UNITED STATES REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE NEED TO HAVE A VOICE
IN THE DIRECTION WE TAKE THIS
COUNTRY.
>> MY VOTERS IN EUROPE TOO FIGH
FOR THEM.
>> FAIR ASSESSMENT THANK YOU FOR